الاساطير المصاحبه لتنقيب عن الاثار اودد
بحيات كثير من الابرياء فهوس حلم الثراء
السريع يدفع بعض المنقبين لارتكاب جرائم
الخطف والقتل بدون اي تردد فقط للوصول الى
الهدف
بيمتلك كثير من المنقبين عن الاثار اعتقاد
ان في جن وراء الاماكن المدفون فيها
الاثار وبيسمح لك بالحصول عليها بعد ما
تقدم له قربان وهو دم شخص بيختاره وفي
اغلب الجرائم بيكون الضحيه احد الاقارب
وخاصه للاطفال وبتكون طريقه التواصل غالبا
بواسطه احد الدليل او المشعوذين
عدد من هذه الجرائم بتكتشفها الشرطه كل
يوم وبتضبط المتورطين فيها منهم اللي قتل
زوجته ابنائه الاربعه في الفيوم واخر
اوهاموا مشعوذ ان في تحت بيته كنز مش
هيقدر انه يحصل عليه الا بعد تقديم دم
شقيقته قربان للجنس فمزقها اشياء
[موسيقى]
واخرها عامل عثر على جثه ابنه المفقود
بسوهاج مقتول فيما دق جبلي لتنكشف بعدها
ملابسات الواقعه
المتهمين قتلوه ايمان منهم بانهم لازم
يقدموا المجني عليه قربان للتنقيب عن
الاثار فقاموا باستدراجه والصحابه بدرجه
ناريه لمكان العثور عليه وقام احدهم
باطلاق عيار ناري تجاهه فاحدث اصابته التي
اوجد بحيته على الفور وقت مضبطهما
الاجراءات القانونيه
وهنا يتساءل المجتمع لحد امتى هتفضل
الاساطير دي تسيطر على عقول الراغبين في
الثراء السريع هل عدد الضحايا السابقين مش
كافي لوقف النوع ده من الجرائم
[موسيقى]